le quartier de la gare à Poitiers un
lieu à haute concentration de fumeurs
ici la prochaine publication des décrets
contre le tabagisme ont fait fumer voir
fulminer plus d'un de mettre une amende
sur mon de la bûche complètement abus de
pouvoir non on est normalement si
liberté fraternité égalité mais alors là
je sais plus où on est là je peux en est
s'il faut ronfler les caisses de l'État
allons-y allons-y mais alors si
maintenant on doit appuie sortir on doit
plus ils nous ont pas encore rationné
sur le sexe heureusement j'aimerais
quand même personne m'en empêchera je
pourrais apprendre des amendes tout à
fait mais je paierai jamais alors de
manière
efficacité pour le droit de fumer je
sais pas ce que la fumée dérange bon bah
c'est vrai il faut le respecter aussi
toute façon il y a eu des gens qui sont
été très malades je serai peut-être
malade aussi j'aurais peut-être pu un
jour bon pour l'instant c'est quand même
un plaisir
en tout cas le futur décret n'a pas
encore profité aux pharmaciens du
quartier qui ne vend pas plus de méthode
pour arrêter de fumer